bonsoir à tous
à
ah ça c'est pas moi
ça y est
donc je vous apprends rien si je vous
dis que je viens parler de la
circulation
mais comme le disait christophe caye
d'abord naturellement j'ai pensé à ça
enfin soyons réaliste plutôt à ça
je me suis dit soyons un petit peu plus
vert donc j'ai pensé à ceux ci haut
j'avoue j'ai des envies de vacances mais
ce n'est pas pour tout de suite puis je
me suis dit on est dans une école
d'ingénieurs
on apprend le généraliste riel
on l'apprend la logistique
donc je vais penser à la chaîne de
production un joystick interne et
externe mais bon encore une fois ce
n'est pas de ça que je vais vous parler
il ya plein de cours là dessus
et je me suis rappelé de quelque chose
qu'on m'a toujours dit souviens toi qui
tu y es bon qui je suis
j'avoue c'est une question très
difficile
mais je me suis dit que certes un
travail ne définit pas une personne mais
c'est quand même un aspect important de
la personne et comme disait tout à
l'heure christoph hein je suis
enseignant principalement je fais des
maths et pour faire plaisir à christophe
justement dans le prochain quart d'heure
et vous faire un petit cours sur la
circulation en maths c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs vous avez l'ecti flyers parce
que et les petits sacs oui un petit
stylo vous allez le prendre tout à
l'heure et sur le verso résoudre
quelques calculs
bon je vois que certains me regardait
avec des grands yeux se demande si je
suis sérieux je vous rassure pas du tout
mais c'est ce qu'on appelle interpellé
et je vais venir dans quelques secondes
en 2012 année durant laquelle j'ai fini
ma thèse il avait très envie de faire
des cours magistraux oui ça arrive
parfois eh bien on pouvait lire dans le
journal le monde la mort programmée des
cours en amphi et bien aujourd'hui je
viens vous parler de la circulation dans
un cours plus particulièrement dans un
coin l'amphi qu'est ce que je veux dire
par là et bien dans un cours en
véhiculant un message une information
une connaissance tout au moins on essaye
et donc je vais vous parler un petit peu
de comment animer en cours j'ai partagé
avec vous une petite expérience
c'est mon expérience c'est pas forcément
la vérité
c'est ce que c'est comment moi je vois
les choses
et surtout pourquoi je vous parle de ça
parce que certaines choses pour être
transposable dans votre futur métier
d'ingénieur quand vous animerez une
équipe quand vous aurez fait une
présentation peut-être donc la première
chose que je vous dirais c'est justement
interpellés c'est ce que j'ai essayé de
faire tout à l'heure interpellé pour
capter l'attention du public
j'aurais pu par exemple commencer par
vous donner une information très
importante comme par exemple que le miel
est le seul aliment qui ne pourrit pas
mais j'avoue que je n'ai pas trop réussi
à la placer avant et je n'ai pas le miel
donc j'ai décidé de rester sur les maths
une valeur sûre
maintenant il faut vous avez capté
l'attention évidemment faut savoir la
garder je vous apprends ainsi je vous
parle du thon c'est très classique donc
je vais pas en dire plus mais par contre
je voudrais quelque chose auquel on
pense pas forcément toujours c'est varié
du support
là on fait des petites présentations si
on a un petit diapos ça va demain vous
êtes dans une réunion qui dure 1h30 2h
dans un conseil qui dure huit heures
dans un court kidder qui dort une heure
et demie deux heures franchement c'est
chiant
mais en fait dans un court c'est pareil
et bien faut penser à utiliser le
tableau il y en a là bas où j'aurais pu
utiliser par exemple faire à des qcm
écrire je sais pas sur des petites
feuilles utilisées le lydia potvin en
tout cas il faut changer faut pas rester
figé sur un seul support
deuxième chose il faut occuper l'espace
on m'a dit de pas trop aller par là bas
donc je reste dans son coin
mais en gros occuper l'espace
physiquement et visuellement
visuellement je parle je dirais des
petits mots à la fin mais il ne serait
ce qu'en regardant un peu tout le monde
faut pas rester juste figé seul au
premier rang qui ose tout le temps la
tête pour dire qu'il est d'accord avec
vous
et physiquement et bien il s'avère que
marcher en amphi c'est un très bon moyen
de capter l'attention parfois on se
balade entre les rangs ça crée aussi une
certaine proximité et quand ils
proximité avec l'étudiant ou avec la
personne avec qui vous vous parlez eh
bien il vous écoute plus
ça paraît mais aussi pour les gens qui
commencent à vieillir comme moi on se
dégourdir un peu les jambes
chose très importante faut savoir
adapter son discours j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure une école d'ingénieurs parce que
justement on en est dans une année dans
une école d'ingénieurs leur adapter son
discours commence d'abord par ces années
son public quand vous êtes dans un cours
dans une réunion bazar dans un court
quand vous avez des étudiants qui
viennent de branches différentes qui ont
des parcours différents et n'ont pas les
mêmes attentes
donc il faut savoir justement il faut
essayer de connaître leurs motivations
leurs attentes pour pouvoir adapter leur
discours
et ça permet aussi bien sûr de capter
sur leur attention
ça permet de les intéresser
mais un autre moyen même tarif et son
public c'est dénoncer ce que voulait
faire on aime tous en général savoir ce
qui va se passer on est tous curieux
on aime bien qu'on lui dise maintenant à
faire ceci mais aussi pourquoi on va le
faire donc donner des objectifs ça c'est
aussi important plus tard dans votre
futur métier
enfin dans votre métier d'ingénieur
quand vous demandez à vos équipes de
faire certaines choses il faut leur dire
pourquoi il faut un objectif je
rajouterais peut-être entre parenthèses
atteignable il faut rester ambitieux
mais dans un cours en particulier si
vous commencez à donner des coups afin
d'aider commandes ya des objectifs qui
paraissent très lointain inatteignable
vous perdez la moitié de la moitié de
l'amphi tout au moins
je vous dirais aussi enfin je vous
laisse lire parce que j'avoue j'ai un
peu de mal personnellement
peut-être vous aimeriez savoir ce qui
est écrit
peut-être que vous êtes intrigués et
bien ce qui est écrit simplement c'est
que tous les hommes désirent par nature
savoir et en fait quand vous intriguer
et bien vous captez encore l'attention
et ces personnes il un bien enfin les
gens on va dire qu'ils commises à savoir
ce qui va se passer ils vont vous
écoutez justement pour laisser deviner
pour essayer de comprendre pour essayer
d'avoir la réponse
mais en fait je disais que quand vous
intriguer quelqu'un quand vous donnez un
objectif quand vous adapter votre
discours est bien on vous écoute vous
écoute plus tout au moins mais c'est
vrai aussi qu'on a tendance à écouter
les personnes qu'on appelle couffin ou
on dit qu'elles sont charismatiques en
fait ça veut dire quoi charismatique
est-ce qu'on est charismatique
est-ce qu'on devient un charismatique
je peux au moins vous dire quand un
moyen qu'on soit charismatique ou pas
d'être écouté écoutez
c'est d'utiliser un langage simple avec
l'âge avec les études on va acquérir un
vocabulaire de plus en plus développer
de plus en plus technique et très
souvent on a tendance à utiliser des
mots complexes des phrases complexes
parce qu'on croit souvent comparaîtra
plus intelligent plus crédible et donc
on vous écoutera plus
or pour qu'une information puisse
circuler au plus de monde possible
notamment dans un cours il faut utiliser
des phrases simples des mots simples
d'ailleurs c'est comme ça qu'un bébé ou
un enfant par naturellement avec des
mots simples
autre chose que vous pouvez utiliser
notamment dans un court ce soient les
moyens mnémotechniques
des choses de la vie courante
les foies des petites histoires on
aimait tous ont adoré tous a priori
écouter des petites histoires qu'on
était petit
et souvent même quand on est grand on
aime encore tout au moins inconsciemment
et quand vous raconter une petite
histoire surtout quand c'est drôle je
dis drôle dans le référentiel date de
profs bien sûr
eh bien ça capte l'attention et on vous
écoute plus d'ailleurs peut-être
certains se rappelleront de l'histoire
de l'ours dans la grotte lorsqu'on
faisait le cours sur les courbes
concaves et convexes ou alors le chien
féroce qui va venir vous dévorer en vous
baladant lorsqu'on fait le cours sur les
pointes de rebroussement
j'ai parlé tout deux bébés en fait il ya
quelque chose qui nous attire chez un
chien un bébé c'est souvent quand un
bébé rigole on va venir vers lui on va
rigoler avec ça va nous attirer
l'humour en fait dans un cours eh bien
ça fait le même effet donc oui ça attire
l'attention mais pas que et bien quand
on rigole quand on rit notre organisme
libère la dopamine est ce qu'on appelle
la molécule du bonheur
et ça procure chez nous un sentiment de
bien-être de plaisir qu'on tenait bien
et bien donc on n'écoute plus en partie
plus si c'est naturel on se rend même
pas compte
comme tout bon prof de maths enfin je
pense l'être je me j'espère tout au
moins j'adore les formules il formule
que j'aime bien soit un succès dans la
vie alors à égal expulse y possède x
égale travailler y égale s'amuser il
aide égale se taire eh bien j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure de y un petit peu parlons
de x2 est alors travailler vous allez
dire non mais attendez il ya qu'un pas
pu nous dire qu'il faut travailler et
bien si
on n'est jamais sûr en fait de réussir
mais si vous voulez être sûr des choux
et venaient sans préparer c'est valable
pour une réunion une conférence de
présentation pour un cours un courses
aso séquence il faut réfléchir ce qu'on
va dire à chaque moment
quelles parties on va avancer mais
attention ça veut pas dire qu'ils vont
venir réciter quelque chose au contraire
il faut laisser une part d'improvisation
est en réalité plus on a travaillé plus
on a préparé mieux on sait improviser et
mieux on sait s'adapter à une situation
qui n'était pas prévu
alors ces terres
se terrent d'abord pour écouter parce qu
écouter
dernier encan une fois de comprendre son
public
d'adapter son discours ce que je disais
tout à l'heure
mais ça permet aussi de donner des
réponses intelligentes c'est quoi une
réponse intelligente en fait tout
simplement
pour une même question il peut avoir
plein de réponses différentes en
fonction des attentes de la paix c'est
encore une fois un étudiant de branche
ou de branches différentes avec des
parcours différents n'ont pas les mêmes
attentes
je peux m'interroger par exemple en
cours est ce que l'étudiant cherche à
accomplir a confirmé l'idée qu'il a en
tête une bonne idée une fausse idée que
je reprendrai pas la même chose en
fonction de ce qu'ils cherchent est ce
qu'ils cherchent une explication
théorique pratique
est séparé en fait plus tard quand vous
allez manager des équipes
vous allez avoir des gens qui font
peut-être le même métier mais qui
viennent d'horizons différents qui ont
des responsabilités différentes faut
savoir s'adresser à eux et il faut
savoir aussi leur donner des réponses
intelligentes
et pour ça aussi il faut savoir poser
des questions
mais en fait poser des questions
ça montre aussi que vous intéressez à la
personne ça vous intéresse vous
intéresser aux autres et quand vous
intéresser aux autres sacré encore une
fois un certain lien sacré un sentiment
de je dirais d'important sur la personne
et on aime tous même quand on est limite
être un petit peu le centre d'intérêt le
lui dire et se sentir un petit peu
important et on a l'impression du coup
de plus appartenant au groupe et donc
d'écouter plus
d'ailleurs que ce soit lorsqu'on parle
lorsqu'on répond il ya langage corporel
qui est très important je suis pas du
tout spécialiste
c'est un sujet en soi on n'a pas le
temps de l'aborder évidemment mais ça
vous intéresse sachez qui a énormément
déçu sur ce qu'on appelle les mécanismes
de la paire situation notamment dans
l'apprentissage un mécanisme on utilise
tous naturellement par exemple c'est
hocher la tête c'est ce que font les
commerciaux parce qu'il paraît d'après
beaucoup d'études qu'on vend beaucoup
mieux quand on change la tête devant un
client
il ya des études statistiques c'est pas
assez pas une bêtise
je vous dirais aussi qu'il faut savoir
établi une relation de confiance
ça peut être le avec vos équipes plus
tard vos collaborateurs ou pour moi avec
mes étudiants et bien
pour établir cette relation de confiance
surtout quand vous prenez pas encore il
ya forcément enfin vous devez montrer
que vous connaissez votre sujet mais
vous devez aussi savoir dire je ne sais
pas
j'ai envie de dire qu' il ya toujours
des questions auxquelles on n'a pas
forcément de réponses qui peut-être
sortent du cadre du cours et bien vaut
mieux dire je ne sais pas
et ne pas essayer de dire n'importe quoi
parce qu' il vaut mieux se taire et
passer pour un con plutôt que de parler
et de ne laisser aucun doute sur le
sujet
et le souci c'est que si vous commencez
à le faire peut-être la première fois ça
passe la deuxième fois ça passe ça finit
par se savoir ça finit par se voir et
quand vous perdez la confiance des gens
à la crédibilité c'est très difficile de
le rattraper
on peut aussi très important c'est
rendre acteur il faut toujours rendre
acteurs et l'étudiant dans un court
parce que quand on est acteur de ce
qu'on vit on se sent plus dans le groupe
en grand une fois et donc on n'a plus
envie d'écouter ça peut se faire par des
interactions
par des ti-culs c1 par exemple demandé
dans le coin est ce que tu es que il
faisait ce que vous avez compris moi
c'est le cas par exemple dans une
réunion essayez de parler un peu avec
les gens même s'ils n'avaient pas
forcément quelque chose à dire mais pour
aussi casser le rythme
et pour finir
une question qui me paraît importante
est ce qu'il ya une manière de faire
j'ai envie de vous dire là ses dernières
minutes
j'ai partagé avec vous une partie de mon
expérience de ma manière de faire en
tout cas ce que je pense être dans
manière de faire peut-être aussi en
étant je dirais inspiré par des choses
que j'ai pu lire ou que j'ai pu voir
quelque part mais s'il ya un conseil
s'il ya une chose que j'aimerais que
vous fassiez vous reteniez
c'est de vous conseiller de faire ce que
vous aimez et que quoi vous fassiez
faites le avec envie et passion
soyez acteur de votre vie
croyez en vous parce que si vous croyez
en vos rêves et se réaliseront peut-être
mais si vous croyez en vous ils vont
sûrement se réaliser merci de m'avoir
écouté